- On this episode,
this talent stops by.
(hip hop music)
- [Gary] You have questions
and I will answer them.
This is The #AskGaryVee Show.
- Hey everybody, this
is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 246
of The #AskGaryVee Show.
We are in the studio with one of
our entire
crew's favorite artists,
one of the favorite artists
of the entire music generation
that's living in the
music world right now, Logic.
- Swag, sup dawg?
- I'm so happy to be here, man,
thank you for the hospitality.
We're gonna
answer some questions.
- The energy.
- Energy's legit.
- I'm happy as fuck.
- Yeah, this is tight.
- Okay, good.
- Life is great.
- Do you know how rare
it is to be a human being?
- Yeah.
Four hundred trillion to one.
- V rare.
You're more likely to do the
NCAA tournament perfectly
on your bracket 11 times in
your life than being born.
- That's crazy, well
I'm glad I'm here, then.
- (laughs) Logic, for the 13
people that don't know,
because you've absolutely
exploded, it's been fun
to watch from afar, gotten
to know your team really well
over the last
month or so, it's just
a really impressive rise
not only on the talent side
of what you do musically,
but how you guys have been so
thoughtful, how you
actually give a crap
about your audience,
who you are as a dude,
and the team that you
surround yourself with.
Why don't you give the Vayner
Nation as I like to call them,
my homies, a little
bit of 411, who are you?
- Yeah, my name
is Logic, you know?
Born Sir Robert Bryson
Hall the Second in 1990,
I'm biracial to a black
father and a white mother
and I grew up in
Gaithersburg, Maryland.
I'm very proud of where I'm
from, and it was crazy, man.
In my household,
I was the only child between
my mother and father, but my
household was predominantly
black, all my brothers
and sisters were black.
Seven brothers
and sisters, you know.
It's crazy, brother's selling
crack and me having to rise
out of that. My father abusing
drugs. My mother using drugs
and abusing alcohol,
making my way out of that.
When I was 17 years
old I left the house,
I got two jobs, worked in
the morning and the evening,
and I would come home
every single night and record
and record and record, because
I told myself I was going
to do it, and long story short,
I fucking made it to this,
we're in my house,
if you can believe it.
I can't believe it's
happened, so fucking dab.
(group laughter)
- Honestly, before
we get into the questions
we need to take a step back.
In such a tough environment,
was there anybody in your life,
whether a teacher or
grandparent or random neighbor,
or was it very
internal that made you look
at your surroundings and speak
to yourself in your own dome
and say "I'm gonna get
out of this and this is how
"I'm gonna do it?"
And in parallel,
'cause I'm getting excited now
'cause I love these
stories, when did you realize
you had the talent to
potentially be able to pull off
this ridiculousness?
- No, I don't think
it was the talent.
First and foremost,
I think it was the mentality
of looking at music and life
in general as a business.
So where a lot of
people look at chains and money
and bitches and all
this shit, like legitimately,
it's like "God I want that",
I saw past all that
and I saw the greats setting
up companies and investing
and all that and I said to
myself, "I want that.
"I want to be able
to support a family."
I never really had a family,
you know, so that's something
I wanted, and I think when
it comes to talent and stuff,
yeah, I don't know,
it's something fun.
I said, "What do I love,
and what do I love the most
"that I can hopefully do for the
rest of my life as a career?"
And then I looked at it
from a business standpoint.
Not just an artistic --
- When?
- As a kid.
- Nine?
- No, I was 17, it was like
when I realized oh my God --
- Did you rap outside,
or battle rap, or play rap?
- Yeah I was such an
introvert at the same time,
because everyone else
was out drinking and smoking
and this and that, and
I wasn't really about that,
and hip hop has
always been kinda known...
- For those things.
- Yeah but there's also
at times, like going out
into the world, it's just
a violent place.
So that's another thing,
I just always kept to myself,
even now. You know what I mean?
When I go out and
people recognize me,
I'll be in my zone and I go
places and make sure I'm secure
and everything's good, but
I'll go somewhere and somebody
will start crying
behind the cash register,
as I'm ordering a McDouble
or some shit and I'm like,
"Oh, that's right."
- This is my life now.
- I forgot.
Yeah, you know and it's so cool.
- Do you love taking selfies?
- Yeah totally, I love
anything that has to do
with fans and interaction
because they're who made me.
But it's not the bullshit
of, "Yeah, they made me",
like don't give a shit. We were
talking about it earlier,
last year before my album
was out, the most important
album I ever did, The Incredible
True Story At The Time,
I literally paid for a tour bus
and spent over six figures to
start in Los Angeles, California
and end in New York,
traveling across
the United States.
Going to fans' houses,
surprising them,
playing my album
before it came out,
sharing meals with them,
spending time with them.
And it was incredible,
and that really let me know,
this is why I make music.
All the bullshit, or the
write-ups, or the accolades,
that's great, but fuck that.
- It's a by-product.
- I can't even believe
that I can affect someone,
where they're like,
"Yo, you saved my life."
- When was the first
time you tasted success?
Like, did you put out
a song on the internet?
- Alright, I'm gonna be honest.
- Please.
- The first time --
- That would be great.
- The first time
I really looked in,
it wasn't even looking in
a mirror, I looked around,
is when I got a check
for a million dollars.
- You lost your mind, right?
- No, I didn't lose
my mind, I was like,
I'd already had a few
million dollars in my account,
but when I looked at one
check that was for a million
dollars, I was
like, "Oh God damn."
(Gary laughs)
Yeah, I was like
this is really crazy.
- But before that insanity,
because that's insanity,--
- Yeah.
and 99.9% of people
will never feel that.
- Everything else was failing.
Everything to me was
like, okay, you know,
such and such
amount of money for a show,
it was like okay, yeah, but
there's always gonna be more.
I never put myself out
where I'm like, "How poppin'
"is Logic, how good am I?
How this, how that?"
I never really thought about it.
I always put it away,
even sitting here and talking
to you, as an entrepreneur,
you're so successful,
but even this, I was like
let me not read
too much into it.
I'm just gonna sit
down with this dude.
I don't like to hype shit,
so I know what you're saying.
I could be like,
"When I signed to Def Jam,
"when I got that check",
but it's like --
- What about the first
time somebody rolled up on you
and really brought a verse
that you put out to the world
to you?
- In what sense?
- As you put out
early music, early, early.
Not like recently, early.
Like somebody just
rolling up at you at McDonald's,
before people cried at
McDonald's, did somebody roll up
on you and regurgitate one
of your hooks or your lyrics?
I think that's where it
gets interesting, right?
- I was back in College Park
in Maryland, this was before
the Young Sinatra mixtape came
out. And the Young Sinatra's
mixtape was the one
that started the foundation,
and somebody was
driving down the street.
- And you heard him playing it?
- I heard him
playing one of my songs.
And I'm like
shooting a music video,
I was in the middle of
shooting a music video.
That to me was why,
it was probably 2010.
I couldn't, that--
- That's what I mean, right?
- yeah, that was it.
- Back in those days,
that's where it
gets interesting.
- Yeah, but that,
that's 'cause like,
every little
thing was so amazing,
'cause I mean, when it
really started, I was like,
"Yo, I'm gonna really,
really do this.
I was 19 and I was homeless
and I, I didn't
have a place to stay
and it was Christmas time
and my homey,
Lennie, who you met upstairs,
- Yeah.
- Big Lenbo,
who's an amazing rapper,
let me live with him and
sleep on his couch for a year.
And, and he was like,
"Yo, like you have a year,
"blah, blah, blah,"
I was supposed to get a job
and things were going so well.
Every week, it seemed
like there was something new
and something amazing and, and,
and he was a land
surveyor for 12 years,
so he would like survey areas,
- Hm-mm.
- Before, you know,
things would get built,
and houses and
buildings and whatever.
And almost a year to the day,
he took care of me,
he fed me, he clothed me,
he let me sleep on his couch
and almost a year to the
day, I signed with Def Jam,
told him to quit
his job of 12 years
and we moved to L.A.
- I love it, man, I love it.
- Yeah, crazy.
- Listen, for
everybody in my audience,
I'm really excited to be here
and you'll understand why,
because the path of the talent
and finding out what you love
and then building around it,
you guys know my spiel,
Crush It!,
that's a long time ago.
It's the execution of the way--
- Lexecution, I'm just kidding.
- Yeah, the
execution and the way that
these guys put out,
when I say these guys,
Logic and his team
think about putting out music,
how they engage with fans,
it's the modern
attention graph story.
I haven't come
across a lot of people
that I think have
totally grasped it
in the way that
you and your team have
and you've got
a great team here.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And I just, it's fun for me,
because I know how this ends up
and to be very frank,
I'll put, I'm gonna put it
on the record,
'cause it's fun for me.
I know this ends
up with you being
one of the biggest
talents in your game.
- Shit, hope so.
- And so like,
it's fun for me to
look at this video in four years
- Nice.
- and tell my kids,
"Like, I told you."
- That's pretty gangster.
- That's pretty
much what I'm doing here.
- That's dope.
- I'm selfish.
- No, but that's real.
(laughs)
'cause I always believe in
speaking things into existence.
In 2010, I did
some random interview
and nobody, I didn't
have a fan in the world,
and I was like
I'm gonna be a X--
- HipHopAtLunch.com, or--
- Yeah, something like that.
In 2013, and I named the date,
I said in 2013
I'm gonna be a XXL Freshman
and I was, you know, it's like,
so just saying
these things, you know,
to cover that
magazine was incredible.
Or to say I'm
gonna release an album,
I'm gonna do such and such
in my first week, you know.
- Is there any
artists you wanna collab with?
I was curious about that.
- Actually there's like--
- I know you haven't,
that's why I'm asking.
- Yeah, no, rap is cool,
but I don't know, I'm
just like, rap is dope,
but I just like, I like...
- What like Blake Shelton
or something? (laughs)
- Nah, I just like indie rock,
you know what I mean?
And like
different shit like that.
I like this dude named Destroyer
and I like, love
Adele, I just love the...
I don't know, it's like
rap is so cool and it's fun
and it's just what I
happen to be good at,
but if I could I would like,
pick up a guitar and like sing
to the world.
(Gary lughs)
But I don't have that
talent, so I'm just like,
giving you what I got.
- Listen,
- You know.
- What you've got is plenty.
Boyd, we got
phone numbers coming?
Everybody on Instagram Live,
start putting up
your phone numbers,
- Yeah,
- We're gonna
call the first person.
- Straight up.
- Ah, you got this?
Alright, so as they're
pulling up the first call,
you can just put it, you can
call it and put in on speaker
and we'll have
the first questions.
- You're going too fast.
- Yeah, it's going fast,
but they're big boys.
Those are two big boys
right there, they got it.
You good, Boyd?
- [Boyd] Yeah.
- Okay, good.
While they're doing their thing,
'cause we don't
have the big, like...
speaker phone here right now,
tell me, when you talk
about all those other songs
and genres, how much
other music do you listen to?
Daily?
- Oh yeah, I listen to
different music every day.
I don't really listen to rap,
especially now, just
like, ever since my last album,
and mix tape, I just,
like I'm so detached from rap.
- Why?
- But not to, yeah, not to where
I don't know what's going on,
I love to know what's
going on with artists,
that I really
appreciate, you know.
I love Cole and
Kendrick and Drake and,
but even, you know,
classic and Nas
and like all types
of dope shit like that.
- Do you have any time to
look at the kids coming up?
Or you just like two--
- Oh, of course, but
that's like, that's like
just ear to the
streets, you know,
like you always--
- Yeah, how
important is that to you?
- I think that's a,
that's a big thing,
because it's like
you wanna know,--
- You got it?
- you wanna
know what's relevant,
you wanna know what's going on,
so that you're able to
stay with yourself--
- Connect and understand?
- You know what I mean?
You wanna vibe
with somebody else,
so somebody who
might be coming up,
who's like a
super dope lyricist,
or whatever the case may be
and you wanna go from there.
- What's going on here?
- Is it going?
- It's about to go, I hope.
- It says that it's calling.
(phone ringing)
Here we go.
- Snap.
- Somebody's about
to be real happy.
(phone ringing)
- [Ryan] Hey, Ryan speaking.
- Ryan, this is GaryVee
and you're on
The #AskGaryVee Show with Logic.
- [Ryan] (laughs) Hey, Gary.
What's up, man?
- Life is good, man.
What kinda
question you got for us?
- [Ryan] Well, I just
wanna know how many hours
you are currently working and
trying to balance family life.
- Are you struggling with
your work-life balance?
- [Ryan] No, I think
I need to work more.
- Respect, okay.
Logic, I'm gonna throw
this at you first, right?
You're a happily
married man now.
- Yeah.
- Right?
- Totally.
- How long?
- It's been a year and a half.
- Alright, so you're
newly wed, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- How long were you guys
together before you got married?
- We were
together for two years.
- Got it.
Do you struggle with,
I mean, obviously you've got
your workspace
here at your home.
Do you think
about work-life balance?
Do you think about,
'cause you're grinding,
you're in this incredible
moment in your career.
Do you worry about
finding the right balance?
Do you feel good
about your balance?
Where you at today?
- It's something that
it's always never-ending.
So for me, for
example, last year,
I performed over
130 shows, I performed.
I was gone like 90% of the year.
- You were gone the whole year.
- Exactly, so it's nice to know,
you really do need balance.
- Was she able
to travel with you?
- Yeah, she was
able to travel, but then,
she's her own person too.
- Yeah, she's got a life.
- So we were able to see each
other and things like that.
So I think sure,
work as hard as you can,
but when it affects
the person you love,
in truly any
type of negative way,
that's when you just
need to sit down and say,
"Alright, how are
we gonna do this?"
And you guys schedule it
out together and you say,
"These days are ours,
or this dinner is ours,
"and these three
hours on Sunday is ours.
"And this is mine,
and that's yours,
"and this is us together,
and this is work."
- Ryan, I think
Logic's got it right.
It comes down to
communication, right?
And the truth is,
some weeks, some months,
some years, it goes perfect,
and other times it's
a real struggle, right?
And so for me,
I've got the greatest
support system of all time.
My wife, Lizzie, is
absolutely the foundation
of my insanity.
I also travel a shitload,
and I've got two young kids.
But you've also gotta
look at circumstances, right?
So much of, I don't
know if you caught this part,
but so much of what makes Logic
is the scenario of
the house he grew up in.
I grew up in an immigrant
household where my dad
left before I woke up and got
home after I went to sleep.
My dad and I slept
in the same exact place
for the first 17
years of my life.
This is true, by the way.
I never went to sleep-away camp.
We basically, outside of a
couple sleepovers that I had,
slept in the same home every
night and I barely saw him.
And my wife also had a
ridiculously successful father,
different,
corporate America success,
not immigrant entrepreneur
success, so he traveled a lot.
So for her and I, it's
not foreign that I'm away
and traveling 50,
100, 150 days a year.
Whereas other people, if you
ate dinner with mom and dad
every night, and
your dad was home at 5:30,
and then you go marry
somebody who's traveling
180 days a week, that's foreign.
So you've gotta communicate,
you've gotta understand
the context of where
everybody comes from.
When I hear you say you
think you gotta work more,
that's a whole
different question.
That's not about
work-life balance.
That is, are you doing
the thing you wanna do?
Are you hungry?
- Personal happiness.
- Yeah, exactly, I mean,
personal happiness
is really fascinating
because the truth is, Ryan,
the biggest that, if
you're watching me,
the one thing I'm scared of is
not everybody has to buy
the New York Jets, right?
I'm trying to buy
the Jets, and I mean it.
So I am gonna
bleed out of my eyeballs
for the rest of my life.
But not everybody has to do
that, so I think it's imperative
that you figure out,
you don't necessarily have
to work more, unless
you wanna achieve a lot more
and wanna be happier
with what you're doing
day in and day out.
- [Ryan] Yeah, I just
realized I'm so passionate
about Treehouse, I'm just
gonna get up earlier now.
So I get up at 4:30 and
just grind, and I love it.
It's good.
- That's awesome, man.
Well, listen,
keep doing your thing.
Thanks for watching the show.
- [Ryan] Love you, man.
- And go listen to
Logic's music, if you haven't,
'cause I feel like you haven't
and you need to immediately.
- [Ryan] Will do.
- You promise?
- [Ryan] I promise.
- Do you promise Logic right
now, he's literally here,
you have to promise him.
- I promise you, just
say, "I promise you, Logic."
- [Ryan] Logic, I promise you,
I'm driving home,
I'm gonna listen right now.
- Spotify right now, bro,
L-O-G-I-C.
It's not spelled ghetto.
(group laughter)
- Ryan, seriously,
you're gonna think back
to this moment in three
years when Logic's literally
one of the five
biggest musicians in the world
and think that was the craziest
shit that ever happened.
- [Ryan] (laughs) I can't wait.
- Alright man, take care,
buh-bye.
Alright, you guys, do
you have it on your thing?
- What a nice guy.
- Great guy, listen
that's the one thing,
and I think, you know what, and
I've looked at a lot of your
fan base--
- Yeah.
- As I was starting
to really dig the last week.
I think you and I have a
very similar thing which is
a funny thing happens when
you put good into the world.
- Oh dude,
positivity is everything.
- Like our fans
struggle to be negative
'cause they know that
we won't like that.
- Yeah, that's so insane.
- So, that's the punchline.
- I never understand
that though and I, you know
here's one thing so like, so
since my motto, my whole motto
is peace, love and positivity.
- Peace, love and positivity.
- That's it.
That's my whole
motto and some people
like hate me.
They're like fuck you, war, hate
and negativity.
They'll say disgusting things,
hurtful things but
that's just the internet.
And I used to always--
- It's not just the internet,
it's just people.
- Yeah, it's just people.
- And listen, if they're
broken inside,--
- Oh yeah.
- they're trying to drag
people down with them.
- And I used to wonder,
I would ask myself,
I would say, "Why do people
hate? I don't understand it.
"I don't understand how, why
would somebody hate on me?
"Why would somebody hate?"
And then, it clicked and I said,
I will never understand
because I'm not a hater.
I don't have a hater mentality.
I have a winner mentality.
A lover's mentality,
you know what I mean?
- I get it.
- So, it's just like
with law of attraction
or whatever you wanna call it.
Like I don't, I don't use...
You know a lot of people say,
"Oh, you know, I wish
"I could travel the world
or I wish I could do this
"with my life but..."
and as soon as they say but
that's it, they destroyed it,
it's over.
- 100%
- If you say
but that's bullshit,
you have to say,
"I'm gonna, I will,"you know?
or before, you know what I mean?
- And, listen, but people front
and peacock all the time.
- Yeah, of course.
- Like, you've
gotta put in the work.
- Yeah, 100%.
(Gary stammering)
- You've got talent and
all this but like again,
reverse engineering your track.
Like, you fucking worked.
- Worked hard.
Definitely.
- And you're not gonna stop.
- No, for sure.
- And that's that.
- Yep.
- I worked every,
like people,
I remember when
I started really blowing up
and people would
hit me up and say,
"Gary, I went to
high school with you.
"You got so lucky,
I'm so pumped for you."
- Lucky?
- And I would reply
and I would be like
"Yo bro, I'm not lucky."
"Remember when you
went to the Jersey Shore
"and banged chicks?
I worked."
- Yeah, I was grinding.
- "I worked"
- That's how I feel,
the same way.
- Because you worked.
Everybody who worked.
- I feel like in
many ways, I missed out,
and I don't wanna
use the word missed out
but I'm saying like, you know,
while other guys were like
going to parties,
and enjoying themselves
and doing all this
other stuff, it's like,
I thought man,
that could be cool.
I was never that
person anyway but I was like
man, if I had that
ambition and wanna go have fun.
Man, that could be so fun
but now I look back like,
I would rather be here
any day of the week
than that was my glory day
and I'm fucking
working at J Crew still.
- I mean, you're married
now and in a different place
but like if people understood
the leverage that comes along
with the success and all the
things that they think they
want by taking shortcuts,
they can get in spades.
- Yeah, that's real.
It's 100%.
- Got one?
Let's do it.
Yeah, I mean, you know.
(phone ringing
and goes to voicemail)
- Oh, yep, that's it.
The kid's gonna be
devastated forever.
- Damn.
- So, as they're
pulling up the next number...
- That's how you know it's real.
- What other interests
do you have outside
the music world?
- Oh, I wanna act.
I wanna act and I wanna invest
but before I invest I
have a number in my mind
that I want in my
personal account, after taxes,
after everything,
just sitting in my account.
- And then you'll
go on the offense?
- Yeah and then
that way it's like okay.
- You can afford
to play and learn.
- Exactly, exactly.
- And learn because
you know you're gonna
lose some dollars--
- Yep.
- but you'll learn--
- Yeah.
- I understand.
- It's all education
process so it's like
totes magotes.
- Magotes.
(DRock laughs)
(telephone rings)
- [Ryan] Hello?
- This is GaryVee
and you're on
The #AskGaryVee Show with Logic.
- [Ryan] Hey guys.
How are you guys doing?
- Sup? Life is good.
- Very good. Very chill,
I like that.
What's your name man?
- [Ryan] My name is Ryan.
- Ryan, how are you?
- [Ryan] I'm pretty damn
stoked talking to you guys.
- Awesome, what's your question?
- [Ryan] I got a
business related question.
I've been working
since I was 18, entrepreneur,
been you know, ups
and downs obviously with
the first three years
you know, you lose money,
you make money,
it's all up and down stuff.
Definitely to a point, to
where I'm trying to figure out
to where, trying
to get to an employee,
to get people under you,
I'm not sure what
the right timing is.
Obviously, trying to
juggle 20 different things
from graphic design,
photography, production side
to everything else
but trying to figure out
when is the best
time to ask for help,
or how to get the right help.
- Can you afford an employee?
- [Ryan] As of right now,
I think we can,
definitely trying to
get to talk to the CPA
and kind of figure
out what's the best move
but that's probably a
question I get, just ask him
to see what the budget would be.
- Did you say CPA?
Like you need to
ask your accountant?
- [Ryan] Yeah, to kind of run
down numbers and everything,
'cause he does all like the
day-to-day work as far as,
you know, we have the mint
as far as the financial stuff
but he kind of
gives the final decision
"Hey, this is how
much you guys can get paid.
"This is how much
you guys can do this."
You know, so on and so forth.
- I mean the
second you can afford,
are you trying to
build a big business?
- [Ryan] Yeah.
I mean that's always, yeah,
that's definitely the
goal to build a big business,
something that can
really start running for itself
and not necessarily, hey
we'll leave the business,
but something to where
we can create infrastructure
to really start running for
itself and not just always
trying to catch what the errors
is at the end of the day.
- If you're trying
to build something big,
the second you
can afford an employee
is when you need an
employee, and then, because
the reality is you
can't do everything, right?
And so if you're
investing in your long term,
invest in your long term.
Like, you should
spend no money on anything,
you should buy no fancy stuff,
and you should put the
money back into the business
and then, so you can
build up the business right?
Too many people
are talking out of
both sides of their mouth,
they want to build
up a big business
but every time they
make a couple of bucks,
a little bit of coin,
they're buying some dumb shit,
like a new pair of Jordans.
- That's real.
- [Ryan] Yeah, that's something
we've invested it to more
like, as far as more marketing,
more step services.
Stuff like that.
- Do you feel like you
can't get to everything
and you really
need that employee?
Obviously you do,
that's why you asked it, right?
- [Ryan] Yeah, I mean to
be honest in my aspect of
the business I think
we definitely do.
I mean every bit of help is
where you know you try to do
10 different things to
keep the business going.
- So, let's break
this down technically.
If you're spending money
that you guys are making,
not on dumb shit, thank God,
but on marketing to
get more opportunities,
you're better off
not spending that money
on more opportunities
and putting it into employees
so that you can then when
you have enough to spend on
new marketing opportunities,
take all that opportunity.
If you're getting your
sales ahead of your delivery,
or what you guys can handle.
- Vicious.
- Then you're gonna struggle.
- [Ryan] Okay.
- The other thing is,
you brought up something
very subtle which
is the right person.
It's not about the right
person when you hire them,
it's about knowing
when to fire them.
- [Ryan] Gotcha, I think that
is my biggest concern to when--
- Everybody's so
crippled, my man,
everybody's so
crippled by the hire.
Everybody's got ego
around the hire. They're like,
"Oh, I'm so good at this.
I got a process.
"I've got good people skills."
I think I got the best
EQ of all fucking time
and I've hired
so many schlemiels
I can't even count 'em.
Because everybody's their best
PR'ed version when they're...
When you're trying to hire
somebody, you know how it is,
the cliche, "Hey,
tell me one of your flaws"
"Oh, sometimes I work too hard."
- [Ryan] Yeah, everyone
always says the same things
but you know I got to
get to the real nitty gritty.
- So hire, hire on
that intuition, feel it,
and then if it's not
right six months later,
three months later or
shit if you know five days,
I've fired people five days in,
it might take three or four
months because I wanna be fair
but I'm like crap, I'm in
trouble. I just know right away
that something
doesn't taste right
so, don't be
crippled by the hiring,
know to be good about the
firing and then you can hire.
You should hire somebody,
by the way, everything
tells me you should
hire somebody tomorrow.
- You're fired.
- [Ryan] Okay,
definitely makes sense.
- Alright my man,
thanks for calling.
- [Ryan] Perfect.
And a quick thing
for both you guys,
Logic, I mean you're
absolutely a made act,
I actually do follow your music
and definitely keep it
up, very, very inspiring.
- Thank you dude.
- [Ryan] And Gary, you as well,
both of you
guys are just amazing
and Gary I will definitely
be sending you over a DM
to do some
business for you guys first
and definitely some
merchandise for you guys.
- Thank you my man.
So wait, when you saw
that we were both together,
if you're fans were
you just like holy shit?
Like peanut butter and jelly?
- [Ryan] I mean,
pretty much, I mean,
I follow your work
as far as your podcast,
I listen to it
every single morning
and as far as, you
know, Instagram Live
we're having to
click that (mumbles)
because (mumbles)
says I should never
watch you on Instagram Live
- Got it.
- [Ryan] So then, yeah,
I put my number down
a couple of times
and hoped for the best.
- Alright my man,
take care of yourself.
- Best of luck.
- [Ryan] Thank you, Gary.
- That was, that was
some gangsta ass advice
you just gave that
dude, that's so gangsta.
- Logic, what about you
as an entrepreneur as a kid?
So you were very artistic,
you're clearly
artistic and thoughtful.
Did you have a
selling DNA where you like go
and buy Blow Pops
and try to sell 'em?
Like did you have that part?
- I'm very ashamed
to tell you a story
that I've never
told anyone in my life.
- Here we go.
- So, so where I came from-
- Let me get coze.
Yeah so when I grew up,
you know what I'm sayin',
I was like hella poor,
I didn't have shit.
- Right, you
stole and sold shit?
- No.
- Damn.
- Because I think
that's okay. (laughs)
- No I went a step further.
I created this
like laminate thing
and it was like this whole thing
I put it on this like
this gangsta lookin' box
(Gary laughs)
and it was like
this like metal box
and me and my boy
dressed up and we went around
and I forget what
the fund was called
but it was basically like
the Poor People of America.
- Oh, oh, oh.
- And we would
knock on people's doors
in a rich neighborhood
and say, "Would you like to
donate five dollars or more?"
'Cause you know
gotta have wiggle room.
- Right, right,
right, right, right, right.
- So it's like well
even if a dollar works out
they're like oh-
- Right you had
room to negotiate
- And yeah and like bro,
I mean we must have walked away
with like a
couple hundred dollars.
- And what did you do with it?
- I fuckin' bought
junk food and shit man,
you know what I'm sayin'?
(Gary laughs)
I was poor, I was a
poor person of America.
But yeah, no that was it.
- I love it.
So you, you hey you
had a little of that.
- A little slight, a
little somethin' somethin'
but that was like
mischievous hustle.
(phone ringing)
- Listen I used to rip people's
flowers out of their yards
and then ring their doorbell
(phone ringing)
and sell 'em right back to them.
- That's hustle. (Gary laughs)
- So everybody starts
with a little bit of that
when you're young and
you don't know better.
- [Nathan] Hello.
- Hello this is GaryVee
and you're on
The #AskGaryVee Show with Logic.
- [Nathan] Hey.
(Gary and Logic laugh)
- So what's your question
and what's your name?
- [Nathan] My name is Nathan
and my question is like
what is your best
advice for startup businesses?
Because like I've been
working on one for three years
and it's just so small,
I don't know what to do.
- Well what kind of
business do you have?
- [Nathan] Well
I'm starting to do like
branch out on social media like
YouTube and stuff like that.
And I have a small
team working on like...
Well okay, so I make
beats for smaller rappers.
- Okay, that's a good start.
So I got a good business idea,
I'm gonna trick Logic
into using one of your beats
and then you're gonna blow up
and everything's gonna be set.
- Yeah fam. (Gary laughs)
- So wait is this more like,
but is this more
like you're trying
to set up your
personal brand via social media,
is that what you're asking,
the best way to go about that?
- [Nathan] Yeah.
- So you're trying
to become a big producer
you wanna be Metro Boomin and
you wanna go in that route?
- [Nathan] Yeah.
- Logic?
- My advice here is
interaction with your peers
and through that so
say there's other producers
so there's a zillion
producers out there, right?
So find some of your favorites
or some people that you would
almost see as competitors
and collaborate.
If you work with somebody else
you guys are always
trying to out do each other
but it's such a
friendly competition
that their listeners on their
YouTube and their Twitter--
- Nathan?
- are gonna find out that
you guys are working together
and they're gonna
wanna hear what you're doin'
with this guy or that guy
and then through that then
other rappers are gonna start
to hear what you
guys are doin' together
or even individually
and then wanna mess with you
and then that rapper might
have you know 2,000 followers
or 5,000 followers,
whatever the case may be.
So to be quite honest,
I think especially
in this day in age
for personal branding
there's two things,
there's one you should,
you know do little vlogs
and talk about who you are
and the things that you like
and the things you enjoy,
How do you produce?
Is it FL Studio, is it Ableton?
Do you use an MPC,
do you like the keyboard?
All these things, do tutorials,
how to make beats,
how to this how to that.
You want people to tune
in and go, I like this guy.
So for everything I want,
I'm gonna come to him.
Whether I wanna buy a beat,
whether I wanna
learn how to make a beat,
or whatever the case may be
it should be all about you.
You wanna be the shit.
You know what I mean?
So I would say just have fun
and connect with others that
are even better than you,
and learn why
they're better than you
and fuckin' take
their secrets and kick ass.
- Nathan, where do you live?
- [Nathan] I live in Kentucky.
- And how old are you?
- Shout out Bryson Tiller.
- [Nathan] I'm 14.
- So you've been
doin' it since you were 11?
- I love this.
- [Nathan] Yeah.
- So listen, I assume
you love Logic and all that,
like have you ever
seen any of my content?
Do you know like my
belief on patience at all?
Do you know anything about this?
- [Nathan] Yes, I've been
watching you for like two years.
- I love you for that.
Thank you.
So here, listen
it's very simple man.
I have a lot of good
things going on in my life.
I would trade to
be you right now.
If you're at a place where
you're watching
my Instagram Live
when you're talkin'
to me and Logic,
you're 14 years old,
you've already put in
three years worth of work,
you're savvy enough to be
paying attention to my content
and listening to
this kind of music,
like you're in
such a great spot.
The biggest problem
is when you're 14
it's hard to be patient, right?
Like, it's just hard but listen,
you need to hone your craft.
Like you're still in the place,
if you think about
mine and Logic's stories,
at 14 there was
no internet for me,
there was for him a little bit
so it's a little
bit different but
like we were just
still working on our craft.
I was still at
baseball card shows
learning how to like set up
tables, trade, how to negotiate.
Logic, were you
writing at this point?
- Oh yeah, I was totally writing
but one other
thing that I do want you
to also think about is like
you being 14
it's like you're like
oh man I just wanna do it
now, I just wanna do it now,
there's a lot of people are like
no I don't wanna finish school.
I don't wanna do this
or I don't wanna do that.
Like first and foremost
remember that if you are blessed
and you are in a position
where you can go to school
and get an education you
do not take that for granted
because it's something
that I did take for granted.
But one piece of
advice I want to give you
and everybody
out there watching,
who's like no I just
wanna get rid of everything else
and just focus on this
one thing that's BS man
because when I was
17 years old I left home
and I worked two
jobs at the same time
while still working on my music.
So no matter how
hard it might feel
or how angry it
can be to just want
to do that one
thing all the time,
make sure you are balancing
your life. It's very important.
- So I'm a bigger
fan of going all-in.
I'm not saying quit
school at 14 and this and that
but I feel like
you did go all-in
by having two side
jobs that enabled you
to survive in some way
to focus on your music.
- Oh completely,
but what I guess--
- Go ahead.
- what I'm saying is
is that if you're a kid
don't drop out of school
because you just
wanna focus on one thing,
unless there is no other option.
For example, I didn't drop out,
I was kicked out of school.
- Right. Or, or if the
market told you so.
If you're a 19-year-old
and you're the best
basketball player in the world
and the NBA is
ready to pay you--
- Oh come on, dawg.
- You drop, right?
- Yeah you get the bread.
- So Nathan, listen.
- [Nathan] Yeah.
- I think more than anything,
like if you're being
very honest with me and Logic
are you good yet?
Like do you think you're great?
Do you think
you're like all-time?
Do you think you're
like Lil Wayne at 14
and like actually
that great already
or do you think you just
still have a long way to go
'cause you're just
getting your shit together?
- [Nathan] I think I
have a longer way to go
but I do think I do
have some skill at FL Studio.
- Yes, yes.
- Okay, so I love that.
So where are you with social?
Have you been promoting?
Are you storytelling?
Are you vlogging?
Do you have a vlog on YouTube?
Like which I think is just a
great way to go about this.
- [Nathan] I will start that.
I'm planning on
getting a camera soon,
it's not gonna be like a big one
but it's gonna
be like cheaper,--
- Do you have a phone?
- [Nathan] I want to be
able to, yeah.
- Well then, you have a camera.
You have a camera, don't
like overthink the quality.
Like, I want you to do the work,
like you gotta taste it.
- Content.
- Like once you have the excuse
that I don't have a camera yet,
you're in excuse zone.
Film a vlog tomorrow on,
you have an iPhone?
- [Nathan] No.
- A Samsung?
- [Nathan] But I
have a good camera.
- Great, I don't care
what you have, flip phone.
Like if you have a
camera on your phone,
film it and put it out tomorrow.
Promise Logic that you're
gonna make a vlog tomorrow.
- Yeah, promise me,
or I'm gonna haunt you.
- Promise Logic.
- [Nathan] I promise that
I'll make a vlog tomorrow.
- Great.
- I love it Nathan.
Nathan, listen I'm
Gary@VaynerMedia.com
I want you to
email me in a month
about how your vlog's going.
- [Nathan] Okay.
- Alright, my man?
Good luck to you.
- [Nathan] Yeah, thank you.
- You're welcome.
I love it.
- Yo, what a little boss.
- Isn't that great?
- That was epic.
- So listen, to make this
valuable for everybody,
are you 26?
- Just turned 27.
- Logic is
twice that dude's age.
- Yeah, oh man,
you're making me feel old.
- When I was 27 and
looked at 41-year-olds
I was like oh that's
like a good size older
and the way I feel
right now I feel like a baby.
Patience.
Like if you wanna
be great at something,
you've gotta put in the work.
- That's 100%
Like do you remember your
first like song you ever made?
- I have it written, I have
it in a big ass box upstairs.
I have the rap. I have it.
- And, how is it?
- It's, it's horrible.
(Gary laughs)
- It's like the worst shit ever.
- I mean, that's it.
- Takes time.
- It just takes time.
But you gotta
really want it though.
You can't just be bullshitting.
- Everybody's
pushing against you.
- Yeah.
- It's all no's.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You start with all no's.
- Yep. And then
you force the yes.
- 100%. I love that.
- Yeah, yeah.
(phone ringing)
- Just start with all no's.
- No, no, no.
You start with no's,
and then you.
- [Victor] Hello?
- Hey man, it's GaryVee,
and you're on
The #AskGaryVee Show with Logic.
- Swag.
- [Victor] Oh, what's up?
- What's up, man? How are you?
- [Victor] I'm awesome.
- Yeah, you swagging? (laughs)
- [Victor] (laughs) Yeah, man.
Logic, gotta love you, man.
Gary, you're really
inspirational as well.
- I appreciate it, man.
- Thank you.
- So, what kind of
question do you have?
What can we answer for you?
- [Victor] I just feel like
a lot of things
that I'm trying to do,
that everyone's
against me on them.
- Like everybody, like your mom?
- [Victor] Yeah.
- Like your ideas?
- [Victor] Like parents
and all that, like friends.
- Fuck them, no,
I'm just kidding.
- I believe that, by the way.
- I mean, to some extent.
- Of course.
- Love your family, but.
- So, what are you up to?
What's your name again?
- [Victor] What I really
love to do is lacrosse.
Like, I've been playing
lacrosse for four or five years,
and there's
nothing more I enjoy to do.
There's just nothing
that I can really do to
take me to the
next level in the sport.
- Let me ask you a
question, real quick,
let me ask you one question.
When you say there is nothing
more that you love to do,
when it comes to lacrosse,
do you really mean that?
Do you really mean that there
is nothing more that you love?
Or could you ever see yourself?
'Cause, one,
you should go for it.
Go for it, if that's
what you want to do,
but I always love to
think long term as well,
'cause you might
want to play lacrosse,
but what happens if?
- You become 41.
- Yes, so, it's like, would
you still want to be involved?
No, I'm just being real,
age takes a toll on the body,
so it's like, is playing
lacrosse the only thing that's
ever going to make you happy,
or are there other outcomes as
well that surround lacrosse
that you can go, have a
great career in lacrosse,
but then, also, see
the end result of like
being a commentator
or being a coach?
- This is exactly right.
- Just being involved?
What do you really want?
- Logic's smart.
- When you're 41
years old with a family?
- [Victor] I just
want to be involved.
Like, I enjoy the creativity,
you know, all of the--
- So, what's the story?
Everybody in your
family and friends say,
even Major League Lacrosse,
it's not like a real lifestyle.
Like you can't become.
- [Victor] Yeah.
- Got it.
- That's bullshit by the way.
- [Victor] I just
come and go to school,
I've been told
I'm extremely smart,
but I just don't enjoy school,
so I haven't been trying.
- How old are you?
- [Victor] I'm fourteen.
- Geez, we're on
fire with 14-year-olds.
- Killin' it.
- What's your
name again, my man?
- [Victor] I'm Victor.
- Victor, so listen,
let me give you
a really good piece of advice,
and make sure your
parents watch this video.
You can always get a job.
- So true (laughs).
- You can do whatever they want
and what you want very easily.
You can go and play
lacrosse in college.
You can try out for
Major League Lacrosse teams.
You can either succeed or fail,
but I got good news for you.
When you're 27, which
is a ridiculous young man,
you can just go get a job.
- That's true,
you can go get a job,
but you can never go back, bro.
You can never go
back to 21 years old
and kind of take
that leap of faith.
You're so young, but like
plan, but just do it, bro.
Fuck that. (laughs)
- You love giving
that advice? (laughs)
- Yeah (laughs).
- Victor, listen, listen.
You're talking to two guys who
created scenarios in their head.
And they lived it.
And not everybody
goes through that,
so you've got to rationalize
what's going on here,
which is you've got two
ridiculously optimistic people,
because they've seen
some of what they've wanted to
achieve through in a world
where most people told them no.
Right?
So, but here's where yours
is practical,
like you're 14,
which is like
four seconds ago, right?
So, you've got to factor
that in, how young you are,
but you're going
to be able to do both.
You're going to be
able to make your parents
and your haters happy,
'cause you can run
the course of school.
Like right now, just be
ridiculously great at lacrosse
and get a scholarship
and go play at
John Hopkins or
Syracuse or be big time,
and you've got literally,
literally eight years
until you have to make
a decision if you want to
become a
professional lacrosse player.
Instead of dwelling on, oh,
everybody doesn't think I can,
go throw the lacrosse
ball against the wall.
- Totally.
- Like just get great.
- [Victor] Yeah.
- Do you know what I mean?
Like, none of this
is going to play out
if you don't get great.
You're going to lose to
them if you don't get great.
So, like every minute
you even think about it,
turn that into thinking
about how to become great
and put in the
work to become great.
Let the chips fall.
Listen, I'm 41.
There was a lot of
kids that were told,
stop playing video
games and go get good grades
and become a lawyer.
And they're making $137,000
a year right now, miserable,
hate their lives, 'cause they
listened to their parents.
Yet, they were
actually great at video games,
and they could be
making $14 million a year
as an e-sports star, but
we didn't know 20 years ago
that Twitch was coming.
Your parents don't
know 11 years from now that
lacrosse is
now a bigger niche sport,
because the Major League
Lacrosse organization made
a deal with Snapchat,
became the first over-the-top
sport on Snapchat, and
every kid 11 and 19 became a
lacrosse fan, because they
used Snapchat the way that
WWF used, you know, pay for
view and it became a good thing.
- Goddamn, I'm inspired.
- Do you understand, Victor?
- [Victor] Yeah.
- So, we don't know what
the next decade looks like.
Maybe Major League
Lacrosse players make
$4 million a year in 10 years.
I don't think so,
'cause a lot has to happen,
but it doesn't
matter what I think.
And, more importantly,
if you make $83,000 a year
or $50,000 a year, or be
like an old school athlete.
Do you know major league
baseball players had jobs
in the summer
in the '50s and '60s.
They loved being
baseball players.
These are fucking
Hall of Famers, Victor.
- Happiness, man.
It's just about happiness, bro.
That's all that
matters is your happiness.
Other people are
going to tell you
what they think you should do,
or what they would
do if they were you,
but they're not you,
bro, they're not you.
So, just be happy,
and do what you love.
Stay passionate.
Be smart.
And have fun, and take risks.
- And be a Wuzzle, a
Wuzzle is a 1984 cartoon,
where two animals
were in one animal.
Be a Wuzzle.
Be a professional
lacrosse players,
and a fucking doctor.
And Grandma
Fucking Victor is thrilled.
- Swag.
I love how we're talking
to 14-year-old kids today.
It's awesome.
- [Victor] If you
look at lacrosse,
lacosse is growing
like disgustingly fast.
- Dude, I'm 41.
Lacrosse has been
growing disgustingly fast
since I was 14, so be careful.
But it doesn't matter.
Be happy and
execute on your thing.
Don't justify your dreams.
Execute on them.
Ooh.
- Yo, put that
shit on a shirt, bro.
- That's actually
what "Ooh" was.
Alright, Victor,
we gotta go, my man.
We wish you well.
- [Victor] All right, all right.
See ya, thanks Logic.
- See you.
- Peace, thank you.
- [Victor] Thanks, Gary.
- Alright, one more.
- Damn that was crucial.
Yo, this is tight.
- This is fun, right?
- This is cool as shit.
- I'm going to see, Ask Logic,
in a couple of weeks on YouTube.
I'm going to be excited.
You should do this, man.
- Yeah.
- It's fun, right?
- Yeah, this is dope, thank you.
- You're welcome.
- This is a
really good experience.
- And it's a good way to
scale interaction with fans.
- I like this energy.
- Do you think we
should start a morning show?
Like me and you
versus Kelly and Michael?
- Yeah, I know. That'd be great.
- You said you wanted to do TV.
- I'll wear the dress. (laughs)
- (laughs) I'll wear it too.
We'll both wear it.
- Alright.
- Here we go.
- You know the person's name?
Or didn't catch it?
- Lafonda.
- Lafonda, you're on
The #AskGaryVee Show.
- What is it?
(phone ringing)
- Alright, we'll get it.
Relax over there, guys.
Sticking phones in
each other's pockets.
- [Man] Hello?
- Yo, this is GaryVee and you're on
The #AskGaryVee Show with Logic.
(phone beeps to end call)
(group laughter)
They got scared.
They were like, you could
hear us in the background,
they got excited.
Alright, before we
get into last question.
Logic, what else do
you want everybody to know?
What else is interesting?
What's on your mind?
- I don't know, man.
I just think one thing
about all of this and just
kind of sitting down
here and talking today
it just shows me like, you know,
you're very successful
in your field. I'd like
to think I'm very successful
in mine.
- You are, you are.
- And like, all that
matter is that we're happy.
I know that when
I wake up every day.
Like literally, I only
have one tattoo and it's
"Happy wife, happy life."
I'm happy with my wife,
I'm happy with my friends,
I'm happy with my
career and I don't know
why I'm saying this
but I wasn't truly happy
until I stopped looking
for acceptance in others.
- Don't justify your dream.
- That's a real thing.
I wasn't truly
happy until I could say,
"No, fuck you if you
don't like this or that."
I did it because
it made me happy.
- It's the best feeling, man.
- Whoever you are out there,
(phone ringing)
do what you do
for yourself, please.
- They'll come to you if you do.
- And buy my albums.
No, just kidding.
(group laughter)
- That will make you happy.
(phone ringing)
- [Sebastian] Hello?
- This is GaryVee and you're on
The #AskGaryVee Show with Logic.
- [Sebastian] Oh my God.
Are you for real?
- I'm super for real,
my man, what's your name
and where you from?
- [Sebastian] Holy crap,
oh my God.
My name's Sebastian.
I'm 15, I'm from South Carolina.
- Alright, Sebastian.
South Carolina
in the Final Four,
you guys all freaking out there?
Is South Carolina
like shut down?
- [Sebastian] Yeah, man,
totally Gamecocks.
They can take it all, so.
- You feelin' good about it?
Now don't lie, what
was your name again?
I apologize,
I'm getting excited.
- [Sebastian] Sebastian.
- Sebastian, did you have them?
Where'd you have
them in your bracket?
Don't bullshit Logic.
- I don't give a
shit about sports.
- [Sebastian] I didn't
make a bracket
but I'm just happy
they're in the Final Four.
- You didn't make a
bracket, that upsets me.
Alright, what's your question?
- [Sebastian] Alright,
so basically like,
I'm stuck between
I just want to do YouTube
and just film my life
or starting a business.
You think I
could collab with them
or stick to one or--
- First of all, bro,
I'm going to interrupt you
and tell you right now
that you filming yourself
and doing vlogs
is a business, bro.
So that's knocking two birds
with one stone right there.
- If you're interesting,
Sebastian.
If you're boring as shit,
nobody's going to watch
and you're not
going to make any money.
- [Sebastian] Okay.
- (stammering)
You need to understand this.
This is the one thing that
everybody has to understand
because this is a phenomenon
because I wrote a book
when you were like zero,
you were like seven years old.
It was called, Crush It!,
and I talked about
the emergence of
YouTube, this thing,
and it's so fun for me to
now see this in real life.
Like 15 year olds are like,
"Yo, I want to do YouTube."
That's insane to me.
That makes me so happy
that I was right, I guess.
But here's the problem.
All of you want to do YouTube.
All of South Carolina
15-year-olds want to do YouTube.
All of North Carolina
Everybody wants to do YouTube.
Everybody wants to be a rapper.
Everybody wants to
be an entrepreneur.
Everybody wants
to be in the NBA.
What you need to figure
out is not only what you want
but are you good enough
to be able to pull it off?
- Damn, that's crucial.
- [Sebastian] Okay.
- You know what I mean?
You understand where
I'm coming from, Sebastian?
I'll tell you this.
You won't know unless you start.
- Yeah, it's true.
Yeah, do it.
- [Sebastian] Okay.
- You see what I mean?
Like you just won't
know unless you start doing
if you're great,
charismatic, funny, interesting,
like by the way, right
now is the time to start.
Everybody's paying
attention to South Carolina.
You're in the Final Four,
document the next three days.
Go into like Wendy's and see
what people are talking about,
go and do.
- Yeah.
- [Sebastian] Okay, okay.
- Hey, what's the
last thing you ate?
- [Sebastian] What's
the last thing I hate?
- Yeah.
- Ate, ate, not hate.
Don't hate anything.
- Hate taxes.
- [Sebastian] Cereal.
- Nice.
- Which one?
- [Sebastian] Cinnamon
Toast Crunch.
- That's a good one,
that's a good one.
- Nice.
- What's your favorite cereal?
- My favorite cereal? Pussy.
No, I'm just kidding.
(Gary laughs)
Cap'n Crunch.
- Me too, me too, the Captain.
Sebastian.
- [Sebastian] Yes, sir.
- I don't feel like
I'm leaving this call
with you actually
doing a vlog tomorrow.
- [Sebastian] Okay,
well, here's the thing,
I have one video on my
YouTube and I'm currently
focused on my Instagram.
I have videos on
my Instagram, so.
- What's your Instagram account?
- My Instagram is @im and then
my name, Sebastian Betancur.
- How do you
spell your last name?
- B-E-T-A-N-C-U-R. Check me
out for some funny videos.
- I'm going to
pull this up right now
because I've got great news.
So you know who Logic is, right?
- [Sebastian] Yeah.
- Logic's going to
follow you on Instagram.
- [Sebastian] Oh my God!
- Yeah dude, can you believe it?
He's the best.
(DRock laughs)
- [Sebastian] This is the best
day of my life, oh my God.
- Okay, I'm Sebastian now what?
- [Sebastian] B-E-T-A-N-C-U-R.
- Dude, Logic, you're
such a good dude for following
this dude.
- What is it, what is it?
- I'm Sebastian but I don't
have the last name down yet.
- Hold on, spell Sebastian
just so we don't screw it up.
- Yo, Sebastian.
[Sebastian] Did you find it?
- Not yet, bro. Spell Sebastian.
- [Sebastian] Alright,
it's I am--
- Oh I am. Hold on,
hold on, my fault. Hold on.
I am Sebastian,
I found you, bro!
- [Sebastian] Oh my God,
this is insane, Gary!
- Yeah, Sebastian.
- Yo Sebastian, you've got
2,500 followers, bro!
- You have 2,438 followers
and your 2,439th
follower is Logic.
Sebastian,
do you understand, bro,
do you understand
that in a couple of
minutes you're going to be able
to text friends and be
like, "Yo, Logic follows me
"on Instagram," and
everybody in South Carolina
is going to shit their pants.
- [Sebastian] Yeah dude. Logic,
please don't ever unfollow me.
(group laughter)
I look up to you so much.
- I am, I am, I did
the same thing.
- Oh, I am!
- No, you put I.
I am!
- Yeah, got to put I am.
Fix it, fix it.
Logic, while you
were trying to find him,
did you hear what he said?
- Yeah.
- He said, "Don't
unfollow me, bro."
- Oh, I'm going to
unfollow you as soon
as this interview's over.
(group laughter)
What the hell? I can't do it.
- [Sebastian] Gary, I just
want to thank you so much
for calling me, I love
all your videos so much.
Honestly, you're just a
motivational person, man.
- I appreciate it, bro.
Listen, I have good news,
I'm a better dude than Logic.
I just followed you and I'm
not going to unfollow you.
- I'm not going
to unfollow you, bro.
- Dude, dude, look at right now.
Boom, there's Logic, dude
and DRock just followed you.
Bro! DRock followed you.
- [Sebastian] Oh my God,
this is so crazy.
I just got 30 followers.
Thank you so much, man.
- Now, Sebastian, here's the
key, who's the first person
you're about to
text as soon as you
and I get off this phone?
- [Sebastian] You know,
I think my dad.
- Your dad?
- [Sebastian] Yeah.
- That's beautiful, man.
I love it.
- Yo, this kid's adorable.
Yo, can I have your hair?
- Yeah, bro, your hair is legit.
- It's legit.
- [Sebastian] Thank you
so much, man.
- Yo, you can
braid that shit, dawg.
- Dude, you got
some nice photos.
- This is hilarious.
- Bryson Cooker, I like it, man.
You're doing your thing.
- You got it.
- [Sebastian] Thank you.
- Hey, listen,
listen, put out more content.
I see what you're doing.
I like it.
Now, you've got to put
more hashtags in your posts.
You've got six or seven
or eight, you need more.
- Yeah, hashtag it.
- [Sebastian] Okay.
- And the other thing is, who
do you think you are, Logic?
You need to reply to every
single person that's leaving
a comment and giving you love
because it makes no sense.
- [Sebastian] Yeah,
I understand.
- Dude, you know
what else is crazy?
Are you paying
attention to what's going on?
Your latest picture
has all sorts of people
commenting that
they're watching you right now.
- I just liked
your last one too, dawg.
Your last, there you go.
- I'm going to
like the one that
you said, "Girls are weird,"
and I'm going to like it.
- Girls are weird.
My wife's weird.
- Don't let those
girls fuck you up, alright?
- My wife fucked me up.
- [Sebastian] Okay.
- Alright, brother, good luck.
- [Sebastian] Thank you so much.
That's amazing.
I love you guys.
- I love you more, Sebastian.
Can I get an "I love
you, Sebastian" shirt?
(bell dings)
Can we get that done?
Alright. I'm being dead serious.
I'm wearing an
"I love you Sebastian" shirt
and then like a Logic
fan's going to roll up at me
like wearing it, guarantee it.
Alright, we're done with that.
- Logic?
- Yes.
- You're a good dude.
- I love you.
- We're good dudes.
- Now, question of the day.
You get to ask everybody
the question of the day.
There'll be
thousands of comments
in Facebook and
YouTube to this question.
What's the question
you wanna put out
to the 13, 14, 15-year-olds
and everybody else in the world,
what would you
like to see them answer?
Might be a good
opportunity for you to
get a little bit
of a feedback loop.
You might be able
to get some insight
on something from the masses.
- I didn't know that
you were gonna ask me this.
- I know, that's why I,
and notice how I didn't give
you that heads up beforehand.
'Cause this awkward pause
right now is everything to me.
I'm gonna rewind
and watch this part.
Shhh.
This is gonna be
an amazing question.
I'm predicting
the greatest question
asked by a guest in the history
of The #AskGaryVee Show.
- Why do you think--
- Oh, this is
gonna be good actually.
- Jesus, 'kay Gandhi,
and Martin Luther King, JFK,
John Lennon,
so many more amazing people
who only spread love
and peace and happiness
and that message were
killed for their cause?
I wanna know why,
why you think that.
I'm just curious.
I have my reason to why I think,
but I don't know,
I just feel like--
- You're curious.
- why so many
incredible amazing figures
that were just
loving and happy met...
- That fate.
- Continued success, man.
- Thank you, you too.
- You got a real talent.
- Appreciate it.
- And a great, great vibe, man.
I enjoyed this so much.
You keep asking questions,
we'll keep answering them.
- Gary Vee.
Here, right now.
Feel my energy.
It's right here.
What do you have to say?
What are you saying?
What's going on?
Get some fuckin' money.
Let's do this!
(Gary laughs)
Let's go!
(hip hop music)